[Music]
[Applause]
Dan Wetzel was going to be at the
hearing I believe this morning Dan
Wetzel Yahoo sports columnist New York
Times bestselling
author uh what did you what happened
here what what happened in the last you
know 12 14 16 hours
here well the the you know litigation is
uh
is is sort of a reason to negotiate in
generally and these types of things and
so the Big 10 and the and Michigan and
harau the parties here were going back
and forth all week with different
proposals on how to not go in front of a
a judge because you go in front of the
judge anything can happen either side
could win or lose so they basically
reached a
settlement Harbaugh and Michigan will
accept the three
games um the Big 10 will publicly
announce that Jim Harbaugh they have no
there's no proof there's no uh
information that says Jim Harbaugh knew
what was going on and they will drop
their investigation and so obviously the
Big 10 gets their three- game suspension
of Harbaugh which is what they wanted
the part that that Harbaugh and Michigan
get is some certainty that going forward
should they get past Ohio State get into
the
postseason and say some other piece of
information comes out
um some other evidence some kind of
question because this is a program
penalty not a Harbaugh they're not
saying Harbaugh did they're saying
Michigan did it so something else comes
out and there are so many unanswered
questions here still how do you drop an
investigation though that you didn't
really investigate I'm guessing that
this was the nciaa not the big
10 the term I I agree they're basically
saying they will not suspend they will
not take further action is is is sort of
the the way it would go so let's say um
they find out I don't know there's more
games involved or someone else might
have known or like we find out just some
different things it's not a major major
thing but you don't have that
uncertainty that the Big 10 might add a
fourth game to it so this was the deal
they're not going to court um this is
not a major legal drama this was not a
Few Good Men uh this was not Harbaugh's
exciting Judge Judy it was just uh all
right this is what we're doing we're
moving on everybody get uh uh let's just
concentrate on coaching football instead
of doing this uh I don't think they
wanted to be just getting it past them
so that was the decision they made
whether was a good one or not for
anybody I have no idea what's the NCAA
do if anything they continue to
investigate so they're investigating
and
um they you know the investig ation
could likely extend past the season uh
or it's certainly going to keep
certainly the regular season they still
want to interview people there's a lot
going on and then when they have their
they have a process they find out what
they are going to allege they give a
notice of allegations to Michigan
Michigan then has 90 days to respond to
that and then there's like a 45 day re
resonse and then you move on to do you
negotiate there or do you take it to the
full there's a long process man the NCA
loves rules processes processes about
rules rules about process so you know it
took six years on a on on the FBI
basketball scandals like I was on here
six years ago talking about that they
finally ended them all and and didn't
really come up with anything so it's a
process so the nca's could extend
certainly into the summer it could be a
year from now they're still going on on
that
so the big what the big 10 was doing was
stepping in and saying we got to punish
him right away we cannot let this wait
and um I thought that was a tough
precedent that they may they may regret
that but that was the decision they made
um so here we go the NCA is going to
continue they're Pro I mean look when
there's an ongoing investigation in this
case
Michigan no one's saying Connor
stallions didn't do it including Connor
stallions okay he hasn't never come out
and said in a statement or anything he's
not talking to anyone but he's didn't
come out in statement saying I didn't do
this this is crazy there's a simple
explanation here so when you have an
ongoing investigation into something the
only information coming out is going to
be either negative or neutral like well
we didn't find anyone new um it's not
going to be like there's an exoneration
here it's just highly improbable there's
an exoneration that they that someone
isn't bring so as it goes forward you
run risk when you're being investigated
that something else negative will come
out something just unlikely this is
going to I I I understand Michigan's
call for due process and all those
things and and you due process is always
a good thing to follow uh but it's not
like this due process has much
likelihood of all a sudden at the end of
this going hey you know turns out
nothing happened but they cheated right
how did who that's why they're not gonna
come up with oh they didn't cheat yeah
turns out he didn't buy the tickets like
yes so that's why when you're if you're
you're the defendant if you will you
know that the investigation isn't going
to clear you it probably it's e going to
be neutral this is it or it's going to
be a it's going to be negative whether
that's a little or a lot yeah Dan they
broke the rule Dan that's it Dan Wetzel
from Yahoo sports columnist New York
Times bestselling author if I gave you
one question for Harbaugh what are you
asking I I I don't know that Harbaugh I
kind of convinced Harbaugh didn't have
any knowledge of this so I if I had to
ask Harbaugh question it would be
um why you know I think what Harbaugh's
guilty of I I'm not really here to
berate them but why didn't
you um stay on top of your staff more
about this is not the kind of thing we
do um this has been a nightmare for Jim
Harbaugh If he if he indeed did not know
how Connor stallions was getting the
information if every other coaching
staff in the country is able to get this
to steal the signs via
videotapes and Game film and sharing the
getting the information from their
friends which pretty much everyone does
why did you think you should go this
route and and and part of it is you have
these these staffs are 70 hundred people
you have all these
20-some super aggressive super
competitive people in your staff in that
grad assistant room you have to walk in
that grad assistant room every week and
say any one of you break any rule none
of you are important enough to break a
rule any of you break any rule bring any
heat on us I'll end your career you have
to put the fear in them and clearly this
guy did not act that way he was acting
in a extremely Brazen manner to break a
rule that had
limited advantages to it and that is
what's taking him
down if Michigan wins the national title
will you recognize them as national
champs yes absolutely okay I don't I
don't I don't they all have each other's
signs let me tell you Dan this reminds
me of deflate gate in a lot of ways
there was a lot of excitement oh my God
the footballs might be deflated all this
oh this is how Tom Brady and the
Patriots win and and we it's the
footballs it's the footballs everyone's
screaming Tom Brady shouldn't play in
the Super Bowl I mean the the takes were
out outrageous I sat in federal court
court and watch lawyers basically argue
now whether the football defl were or
were not deflated they never really
proved they were even deflated but they
were arguing essentially whether Tom
Brady was good at
football it was because one side was
arguing he's cheating and that's why
he's good and the other side's going no
he's Tom Brady um and so whatever
happened with the footballs the
footballs were fine after that and he
won like four more Super Bowls with two
teams so this is cheating they broke the
rule there should be a punishment but
the idea that this is uh some
overwhelming Advantage everybody has
everybody's plays the coaches staffs
share what they find with their friends
on the other staff everyone's got each
other's plays is this an unfair
Advantage is over the top absolutely I'm
not exonerating it at all punish him but
to sit there and be like we got to ban
them from the playoff or you're not a
real Champion they don't have the plays
right now if they win all these games uh
they're absolutely I can't I can't
overstate like it's a thing but it I'm
not going to overstate that this is the
greatest crime in the history of
football thank you Dan have a great
weekend take care that's Dan wetzell
Yahoo sports columnist New York Times
best selling author